does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not i'm
just calling you out for saying that we
are stranding americans in afghanistan
oh my god
that's unbelievable and the bleep is
about to hit the pan so what is this
really about right now why is joe biden
doing this right now why is anthony
fauci up in the game right now and the
answer is because this failure in
afghanistan is truly horrifying so adam
chef you never
expect to hear a true thing out of adam
schiff who again has a pup tent it is it
is placed right outside of the msnbc
green room he spent four years lying
about how there was going to be
inevitable evidence that donald trump
was a russian cat's paw
right you remember this okay but adam
schiff who can always be counted on to
back whatever is the democratic talking
point of the moment
he uh he did not when it came to
afghanistan yesterday it was very
unfortunate for the biden administration
according to
the hill
house intelligence committee chairman
adam schiff said it was very unlikely
the u.s will complete its evacuation of
afghanistan by the august 31st deadline
he said quote i think it's possible but
i think it's very unlikely given the
number of americans who still need to be
evacuated it's hard for me to imagine
that all of that can be accomplished
between now and the end of the month
i'm encouraged to see the numbers of
people evacuating increasing readily to
the point where we evacuated 11 000
people in a single day nonetheless given
the logistical difficulties of moving
people to the airport and limited number
of workarounds it's hard for me to see
that could be fully complete by the end
of the month
he said i'm certainly of the view we
maintain a military presence for as long
as is necessary
to get all us persons out and to meet
our moral and ethical obligations to our
afghan partners so schiff admitted that
there are people who are stranded he
admitted that getting people out by
august 31st is unlikely
he said he is concerned about the
security of the airport he said i think
the threat to the airport is very real
and very substantial and he says this
makes an attractive target for isis it
does it is one runway and the gates are
not properly guarded and the people who
stand between isis and the americans
are um the taliban
and finally schiff admitted that the
intel community knew from the beginning
that the afghan government was likely to
collapse if the united states pulled out
and the taliban was likely to take over
which means that joe biden was just
lying that he was just lying
[Music]
intel committee member jason crowe
another democrat said i do not believe
at this point that i have any evidence
of an intelligence failure
so um then it's just
then it's just joe biden's fault
which is why he has to distract
so jen saki yesterday just gave an
astonishing statement
she was asked by peter ducey about the
americans currently stranded in kabul
her answer was to play semantic games
over whether they are actually stranded
or not
um i'm pretty sure that the americans
who are now being relegated to their
apartments
in kabul and are deathly afraid of
walking out the front door for fear they
will be beaten by the taliban and
there's nobody coming to get them they
probably feel a little stranded a little
by the way every major
news outlet in the united states has
called them stranded because they are
here's jen saki denying it
does the person have a sense that most
of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no american
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i set when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home okay
no
now she's shifting the conversation
right he's saying they are currently
stranded and she's like they're not
stranded he's like is that your position
it's like no i'm just i'm just saying
that we're going to go get them because
it's like saying that we're not men
stranded on the beach at dunkirk
okay they were and then people went and
got them they're americans currently
stranded in kabul the question is are
you going to go out there and are you
going to save them well one of the
questions that needs to be answered
before you even get to that is how many
americans are there even in kabul well
the good news is the american government
has no damned idea in fact the american
government is not even willing at this
point to say how many americans they've
gotten out they're giving you broad
numbers as to how many people they've
gotten out a huge majority of those are
afghan nationals who worked with the
united states which is fine but
they are not willing to say how many
americans are among that group
why well there's only one reason for
that in terms of public relations the
only reason for that is because the
number is kind of low here is uh here is
major general hank taylor admitting he
doesn't know how many americans have
even left
you mentioned that 42 000 have been
evacuated since july
uh is that 42 000 just on military
airlift or does that include the
commercial
uh and chartered planes yeah so that
that total number is uh u.s military
plus u.s
uh civilian state department some of
that was state department uh contract
error that went out also earlier do you
have any breakdown of the number of u.s
citizens in that 42 000 that have gotten
out um i do but i don't have that right
now uh well they don't have that and
then john kirby of the pentagon said the
same thing he's asked how many americans
have actually been evacuated well we
don't know or we're not going to tell
you what do you do
that's the most important number here in
the number of americans
so if it's just a matter of checking the
number
can you do that and give it to us or if
you're being deliberately vague don't
tell me why you're being deliberately
vague i think i'm just going to leave it
at several thousand right now dave well
then tell us why
because i think uh the number is very
fluid um and it literally changes nearly
by the hour it's not more fluid than
than these eleven thousand and thirty
seven i'm gonna leave it several
thousand right now oh my god
that's unbelievable that's unbelievable
and that is from the spokesperson for
the pentagon so uh things are things
must be going great if they won't even
tell you how many americans they've
actually gotten out at this point things
must be going just spectacularly
meanwhile the taliban has set a red line
the taliban has said openly that if you
stay beyond august 31st then bleep gets
real here's a taliban spokesperson
saying this yesterday to sky news
if the u.s or the uk
wanted to extend the 31st
of august deadline in order to
continue evacuations out of the country
would you agree to that no no
this is uh something uh you can say it's
a red line while there is no need for
for that i think that it will
deteriorate the relation that will
create mistrust between us if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
so it will um
provoke reaction and the bleep is about
to hit the pan because we're not getting
everybody out by august 31st and the
taliban have said that's the deadline
so what is joe biden willing to risk
here to get americans out we're about to
find out in very short or the military
says has one week to decide to extend
the deadline and that's it
and past that they don't know what they
can do
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video